hello everyone a lot of people requested
this game so here it is I don't know if
it's really the last Queen sacrifice of
2017 but until I'm proven wrong I'm just
gonna go with it from 31st of December
to 3rd of January ye the Chinese
Grandmaster is playing against the
number one check grandmaster Davi navara
it's a chess match it's a four game
chess match and the winner of this match
will be given $20,000 the loser will
also get $10,000 so it's not a bad deal
even if you lose you get $10,000 the
match is being played in yanqing in
China and so far they've already played
three games today was the third game the
result is one and a half each and
tomorrow is the final game if tomorrow
will be a draw then they will go in two
tiebreaks but I will put the details of
the match in the description below so
you can check it out so let's see this
game way he has the white pieces and
it's it's really a wild game we have E 4
and C 6 by navara for all you caro-kann
enthusiasts d4 d5 and E 5 the advance
variation of the caro-kann Bishop to f5
and here I thought that someone of wayy
style would definitely go for G for
something like G for the bayonets attack
but in fact he goes for 9th to d2 we
have be 6 and the knight to be 3 it's an
interesting idea I don't think I've ever
seen a core account being handled this
way tonight will be very useful here as
you'll see in the game Knight to d7 we
have Knight to f3 a6 now Bishop to e2
and c5 and here c3 was played h6 and now
D captures on c5 by way E and the Bishop
captures on c5 and this is the idea
behind this Knight to b3 opening if you
play Knight captures on c5 here if you
don't want to give up the bishop pair
then Knight can come Knight F to d4 and
after Bishop moves to g6 white and
castle and it's a wonderful position for
white white is already threatening f4 f5
to break open the position the black
king is still stuck in the middle if
black captures on b3 you can even play a
ache after some b3 and then you get an
open a file for your rook so it's quite
a dangerous
so after D captures on c5 navara plays
Bishop captures on c5 we have Knight
captures on c5 sorry about that and
knife captures on c5 and Bishop to e3
now attacking the knight on c5 rook to
c8 and hear ye castles we have Knight to
e7 Knights to d4 and here
no Bishop to g6 or anything like that
simply castles never our doesn't mind if
we captures the Bishop on f5 simply
Knight captures and f5 will come and
that night will be pretty much stuck
there on f5 I mean it's a great square
for the Black Knight for the dark knight
only way white will be able to take it
away is either by capturing your Buddha
light square Bishop or by pushing g4 so
we have a for Bishop to h7 and a5 now
Knight to c6
we have Knight captures rook captures as
d5 pawn was attacked and Bishop to d4
and Namara plays Queen to g5 bringing
the Queen into the attack and rook to a3
a more safe for a safer approach would
be something like f3 okay this is a bit
counterintuitive you do block your Queen
and Bishop put the f3 pawn but then
again you deny the night it is very
important efore square but okay way he
goes for rook to a3 probably where ideas
of playing something like c3 and rook to
g3 to bring the rock into the attack
Navarro plays Queen to a5 now he brings
more pressure to the d3 square now to
join the knight can jump to d3 before in
the night but Knight can come to d3 as
we said and the g4 attacking the Queen
Queen to g6 and now f4 way is now
threatening f5 the Queen will be
attacked after capture on f5 we will
simply capture the Nikon d3s it will no
longer be defended
so Queen to b4 not allowing a fight with
tempo and we have Bishop to f3 attacking
the Queen and here navara goes for it he
plays Queen captures on f4 and he allows
this it seems like a winning move for
white Bishop captures undies
but actually navara went for this on
purpose he captures on b5 now given up
the queen
we have rook captures Queen on f4 and
the Knight captures on f4 so given up
the Queen for a bishop and the rook
doesn't really give you like equality in
material sense but his position is quite
quite good and here something like rook
to b3 may be preparing a move like b5
would be okay for white but wait played
Bishop to e3 he attacked the night and
if an f4 Knight the d3 now the knight is
protected by the bishop on and on h7 the
threat is to capture d5 pawn and you
really don't have a way of defending
that point you can only play Bishop back
to d4 and this is what we played so
basically he just wasted a move that's
not really something you want to do
after like just sacrificed his Queen
rook to e8 and now with a double attack
on the pawn and Queen to f3 now if you
capture d5 pawn we captures the d5 pawn
noir goes for it Knight captures on e5
we have Queen captures on d5 and now
Knight captures on g4 grabbing another
pawn and this is this could have been a
very important pawn in defending the
white king it will be hard to solidify
okay could play h3 but black could
always just break open the position rook
to a one-way he has to bring this rook
back into the game we have worked to g6
now this rook to g6 comes with a threat
of eternai to f6 check or night III
check picking out the Queen so we place
queen capture some b7 grabbing that
point in getting the Queen out of the
way and we had night the e3 check and
here King 2 f2 is actually the only good
move if you play something like King to
h1 then this very annoying group to g4
comes and now there's a threat of Bishop
to g4 checking the King and also
attacking the Queen but you can't really
move the Queen if you move the Queen
then Bishop to b4 will be checkmate so
you don't really have any options here
if you capture for example
Bishop 3 4 check Queen captures rook
captures it's 2 rooks
the rook and the bishop easily winning
position for black so after this night -
III king - f2 was played now we have
Knight to g4 check King back to g1 and
out Knight to e5 check and here Navarre
plus or ye played King to f1 and this
was it's not the losing move but it
definitely gives Navarro more than he
should have a better move here is
actually King - h1 the exact same move I
just said that that didn't work but it
didn't work when the black when the dark
night was an e3 now that it's an e5 it
actually works now rook to g4 doesn't
work because simply rook to e1 the rook
is now guarding d4 square when tonight
was an e3 the rook couldn't guard e4
square so here after something like f6
okay you do defend tonight but white is
white is winning here he can black
doesn't really have a threat or I can
simply push be five a-six a-seven
a-eight but after this Knight to e5
check King to f1 by Navarro by way we
had rook to f6 check King to g2 and now
rook back to g6 check and again navara
has the option of blinking - h1 but he
plays King to f1 and we have rook to g5
here bishop characters on e5 and now
Bishop to d3 check King to f2 rook
captures Bishop we have worked to d1 and
this rook to d1 is actually the losing
move for way but you'll see why the idea
the idea for way here is to play Queen
to c8 check and I only after King moves
to h7 only then move the rook but -
you'll see why after rook to d1 and noir
played rook to e2 with check we have
King to f3 in our rope to f5 check King
to g4 h5 check we have king the King to
h4 and now rook to e4 check and in this
position we resigned to the game but as
you can see in this position there would
there wouldn't have been a rook to f5
check if Queen to CH check was played
first before rope to d1 then rook
couldn't come to five and none of this
would actually work for black it would
probably be some sort of a draw I mean
the game would continue but there would
be no immediate win for Davin navara but
okay the she played rook to d1 so King
to g4 h5 check King to h4 rook to e4
check in this position where you resign
to the game what would follow is
something like King to g3 rook to e3
check and now it depends really if you
play something like King to g2 then
simply Bishop three four check picks up
the Queen Queen captures rook captures
and it's two rooks against the two rooks
against the rook also something young
Gustavson often says his favorite kind
of endgame is the one where he has a
rock and his opponent doesn't but after
rook to e3 check instead of King g2 you
could also play something like King to
h4 but then comes g5 you have to capture
on h5 King captures on h5 Bishop to e2
check King to h6 and rook to h3 this is
checkmate so a very nice game by Davi
navara a very brave game the Queen
sacrifice wasn't exactly crushing but it
was it was an active game and he managed
to pull it off
we didn't didn't maneuver with the King
the way he should have but you know it's
always hard when it's an open position
and your king is running loose so that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it if you
have any other games featuring an Ice
Queen sacrifice between grandmasters
played on the 31st of December do share
in the comments but until then this is
the last Queen sacrifice of 2017 as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here think all for watching and I
will see you soon